hello folks welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics everybody else moves Concepts
around they think they're doing physics
we have a great day today we're going to
be doing a little bit of gyroscopes
something uh NASA ran a few years back
about 20 years now and um it's known as
gravity Pro B and what they did is
according to them this is their
conclusion they moved time around they
uh drag time around the earth that's the
conclusion you spent $1 billion dollar
to reach that uh result that conclusion
okay anyways we're going to start with
our um Extinction segment and I forgot
Merry Christmas and a Happy New Year to
everybody I hope hope everybody has had
some happy holidays I surely did in the
company of my family so we did well I
hope you did as just as well anyways uh
we're going to do a little bit of
Extinction uh talk about some of the
subjects related to Extinction and then
we're going to move on to some of the
questions that people asked some of the
comments people made going to try to
address those and finally we're going to
get to our gyroscopes and gravity Pro
bam and the dragging of time okay okay
so let's begin with our uh first one
here and we have this gentleman his name
is Jeff Bezos okay discusses plans for a
trillion people to live in huge
cylindrical space
stations and Jeff basos says F say we'll
be uh we'll all be living inside massive
cylindrical space stations one day okay
and he says these habitats could allow
an astronomical number of humans to
survive so we're going to be out in
space Bill trillions of people forget
about billions and he said if we had a
trillion humans we could have at any
time a thousand mozarts and a thousand
Einstein I don't think I would mind a
thousand mozarts uh but I don't think I
could stand a thousand Einstein anyways
the only way to get to that vision is
with giant space stations the planetary
surfaces are just way too
small and then his uh rival another fell
who's doing some of the space stuff Elon
Musk claims to be working towards making
humanity
multiplanetary and
establishing cities on other planets
like
Mars and so the question is uh whether
we're going to ever make it to a
trillion people and whether we're ever
going to make it to Mars or any of the
other planets I mean not just sending a
probe we've done that but the question
is will we be sending people there and
if we send people there will it just be
you know like yeah we we did touchdown
came back that's great but I mean are we
going to live there are we going to
really terraform the planet or whatever
and that's a different story you know I
mean if it's just a project to send
people and say we did it we could we
have the technology to make it there and
to stay there for a couple days a couple
hours whatever and then come back yeah
uh great you know but uh I don't know if
you want to spend a billion dollars in
such a project okay but this is what
these people are into
and as far as a population is concerned
I don't know about that here you have
um
uh I was going to show you the global
population I guess I don't have it
anyways uh the issue is that population
is uh grinding down uh we're we're still
increasing in the world we're becoming
more and more uh but it's uh arithmetic
we're not expanding exponentially
anymore and so the the question is you
know what's the end of all that uh you
know we're turning the corner so to
speak we're approaching the ASM toote
and if we don't have uh any growth in
population we have no demand we have no
demand or less Demand right at some
point the uh global economy has to come
through a halt in some way one way or
another so you have to figure out what
that implies for
Humanity okay and uh fell says asked a
question he says mimetics is it nonsense
or is there a rational way of talking
about it and yeah it's got to do with
memes and uh it's like an idea
replicator so if you're uh looking at
this uh it just means that just like um
you know some things ex uh evolve over
time like humans animals Etc plants uh
the same thing applies to ideas they go
from mind to mind and the thing spreads
if it's I guess a good ide idea you know
I think that's the way they look at it
uh yeah you can talk rationally about it
but the question is whether uh what is
that really mean you know you had um uh
Marx he talked about the uh
materialistic dialectic and before that
his teacher hego he talked about you
know philosophical dialectic and it was
The Clash of ideas from where where you
get a synthesis and so on down the line
and this is the same thing it's just
another version of what Hegel already
put on the books yeah you can talk
rationally about it but I mean what does
it mean just means that ideas propagate
I guess if uh everybody buys into it
which doesn't mean that it's correct you
can have the Flat Earth notion right and
it propagates and yeah okay so does that
mean we're all correct that we have
mother uh uh faithful reflection of
Mother Nature's universe so you know the
fact that ideas propagate doesn't mean
that the ideas are rational okay and I
think that's more
important okay um here we have a fell
and he says uh we haven't lost genetic
diversity every human has a unique
genome except for twins triplets Etc as
long as population is increasing so is
genetic diversity well we take a
different view here we're saying that
genetic diversity humans have lost their
genetic diversity and essentially we're
all clones of each other more or less
you know that's that's where we are
today and here's uh evidence proof for
those of you who like evidence and proof
and want people to twist your arm
convince you here it is uh this came out
in 2012 you can look it up uh there's a
couple studies at least on this subject
and that's that chimpanzee populations
living in relatively close proximity are
substantially more different genetically
than humans living on different
continents and what they showed really
is that uh you've got these um monkeys
these chimps in Africa and they looked
at a troop of like a hundred of these
animals and they discovered that um they
have more genetic diversity within the
Troth than the entire human race 8
billion people and so the question is
you know we're not a very genetically
diverse species and what's happened to
us I mean we're 8 billion people we
should have more one with thing right
more genetic diversity
because we're so many it's the opposite
we're all clones of each other whoever
you marry today is your sister or your
brother from a genetic point of view and
um and so what can I tell you you know
uh this fellow does
not does not share that same thought
he's um operates with a different set of
assumptions and yeah you reach different
conclusions but I can tell you what we
do here and we're saying that we've lost
genetic diversity and why because we've
been in breeding for 200,000 300,000
years we haven't married any other
species we have not enriched our genetic
pool and here you see what happens when
you do that when you inbreed okay and a
lot of people don't really understand
this so it's good to rub it in um this
these are the Amish they they were like
maybe anywhere between
500500 people uh 350 years ago today
there's 350,000 I guess mainly in the
United States and uh they looked at a
group here of about 40,000 which came
from about 400 Founders you know the
founders effect says for religious
reasons the Amish marry only within
their Community the population remains
primarily derived from the original 400
Founders the old order Amish in
Lancaster that's County in Pennsylvania
I think represent one extremely large
family with about 40,000 members in
other words they're all from the same
essentially the same families they've
been inbreeding for 350 years they are
very distinct group genetically and
culturally and the genetic variation
which within this community is so narrow
and there you see some of the studies of
some of the genetic studies that they've
done there's a paper on that and uh I
just wanted to show that there's like
what is it about 30 um uh problems that
they found with their genes uh
similarities and things that are not
very healthy so the point here is that
yeah you if you inbreed if you marry
your sister and then uh your kid uh me
also me marries his sister and so on and
down the line well at some point you're
going to run into some kind of problem
and that's essentially what has happened
to humans over the course of the last
200 300,000 years we've been in breeding
and that has to have a delerious effect
after you know so many thousands of
years that's the argument we have here
so no we are not a very genetic diverse
um uh species and the fact that we have
more and more people being born every
day does not increase genetic diversity
you would think uh there's mutations
that accumulate etc etc but um you have
to factor in Founders effects and you
have to factor also um population
bottlenecks okay so and we've had quite
a few of those history whether we're
going to have some of them now I don't
know not maybe due to um diseases as it
was in the past maybe yeah due to Wars
but I think that's going to be a drop of
water in the ocean we're already
probably the beyond the point of no
return we're already uh Gone we're
already equal equality not in uh our
social and economic status but we are
all equal genetically okay so if that
helps anybody out there there okay some
f says here I'm 100% sure M's president
of Argentina okay ideas will make the
overwhelming majority of Argentina's
people much better off relatively
quickly because I talked about mle the
other time mle just wants very small
government with a lot of Liberty and
opportunity no not no government charity
uh naturally returns into churches black
markets will disappear standards of
living of living will begin to rise okay
okay um I've got a problem uh with uh in
general with Libertarians and uh what I
call Narco caps the Narco
capitalist um do I disagree with their
ideas not really that's not where where
the issue is uh what mle is introducing
into Argentina might be good you know I
don't know we'll we'll have to see that
in the future for sure we can be sure
one thing in the near future it's going
to be very rotten for the argentines
okay for the people people living there
it's going to be a big blow to a lot of
poor people especially okay and that's
already a farone conclusion the
government even says that yeah it's
going to get worse before it gets better
okay now whether it gets better uh
that's in the long run but as one
Economist one said in the long run we're
all dead so we don't know what happens
in the long run those are wishful
thinking on the part of a lot of these
Libertarians and Narco caps but my
argument is a little different and
that's that the whole planet forget
about Argent now forget about Indonesia
Pakistan you know all these countries
are in a serious condition their
economics are terrible in fact the US
economy is quite terrible the other day
I was reading that the debt the the uh
interest on the debt is surpassing what
uh what we're producing the the the
added uh GDP and so we have to look at
that and a lot of that GDP is not real
manufacturing or solid things you know
uh thing tangible things but they're uh
services so we're creating a lot of
services that goes to GDP but it's just
a balloon that's growing that uh is not
real growth the real growth is in the
material things and you know
manufacturing and a lot of stuff related
to uh uh tangible things like houses uh
roads Etc you know that's you know
cities growing Etc you that's uh that's
uh not growing at the same Pace as the
economy either so the question is you
know uh whether um the policies that
they will Implement in Argentina will
have any effect in the long run meaning
you know will Extinction come before any
of those policies really have any effect
okay so you know again we don't know
what the future brings I can only tell
you that we're going extinct and I can't
tell you when but uh it's just around
the corner we're not that far away and
so I don't know which will come first
whether the good results from
libertarian politics or
Extinction we also have the situation
where we're having several Wars today on
the planet uh the empires are clashing
you have the Empire of Russia the Empire
of China the Empire of the United States
these Empires are coming against each
other you know they're trying to
encroach on each other's economics and
uh of influence Etc and who knows what
that will bring you know how that will
turn out so that's another thing we have
to pitch in I mean for all we know this
is the last year of our lives right
2024 think about that something to think
about says nothing can have a value
nothing can't cannot is when humans will
become extinct okay so yeah it's
becoming digital we have some digital
money right already there are no logical
no logical people who place value on
digital text or anything okay great
money and mo thinks that is okay and so
he reaches this conclusion and by money
being no more equaling humans becoming
extinct uh yeah I mean if you take it in
that direction I guess that's the
conclusion you reach but I I disagree
with this Spell's assumptions okay okay
um follow continues and he says the
following he says you said species is a
concept absolutely and Extinction refers
to a species right to a species okay uh
what about the universe well the
universe cannot become extinct because
the universe is not a species it's not a
living entity and the word uh Extinction
here is not like uh when you say or you
use the fire extinguisher to turn you
know to blow away or extinguish the fire
right it's not in that sense and so when
you use that sense then you're obviously
going to get some kind of contrad
addiction no we're talking about
extinguishing uh in the in the context
of a species which means that the last
um uh member of that species finally
dies okay and there's no more of that
species that's what we call Extinction
and so to take it and apply that same
notion and extrapolate it to the
universe now we're talking about
something else what if it became extinct
yeah again you can't say that the
Universe becomes extinct uh again uh
I guess he's trying to say that the
Universe does not become extinct does
not exist anymore and again we can't say
that about the universe because universe
is matter and space it's a concept it's
not a thing okay you can say that matter
disappears somehow uh becomes space
converts into space mors into space fine
and then that's not the same thing as
saying it became extinct okay it just
doesn't exist and so you use exist for
this an Extinction for spee you should
not confuse those two terms but this V
apparently does he says Extinction
refers to anything no absolutely not
Extinction only in a the ordinary speech
refers to uh anything when we say we
extinguish a fire that's not the notion
that we're using here okay we're using
the notion of extinguishing in the
context of um species of living entities
or it could be plants or animals right
any type of species yeah existence is
the opposite of Extinction and vice
versa absolutely not and Extinction can
happen in any manner and this is just a
logical conclusion of money becoming no
more as dinosaurs becoming no more no
money becoming no more is not that money
became
extinct but this is what this fell
that's where he's getting confused he's
using the term of extinguishing a fire
in the context of you know U dinosaurs
and vice versa extinction of the
dinosaurs in the the context of
Extinction of money dinos and money both
became extinct no absolutely not okay
and so all I can say is yeah you got to
keep your language straight and you got
to Define your terms very clearly and
you can't use the word extinction in the
uh notion of ordinary speech which is
extinction of anything where where it is
equated to e exist and so or
non-existence and so they say oh he
ceased to exist he extinguished himself
he's no he he became extinct and we
don't talk like that you know in physics
it's either a species or becomes extinct
or um or we don't use the word extinct
in the context of saying the uh you know
an atom became extinct or I don't know
the fire became extinct you have to
separate those two
Notions okay let's move on here to um
some of the questions people asked uh
that leads us to the subject matter of
today it's got to do with several
subjects but they're all related to
physics let's go with the first one fell
says says the way I understand the block
Universe remember we talked about the
block universe meaning uh this SpaceTime
that started at the big bang and
expanded all the way to today and they
treated it all as a single block despite
that they cut it into pieces of thyme
you know thyme slices and these slices
are growing but then they take that
whole shebang and they say look it's a
block Universe like it they treat it as
a single thing like it's got no time or
or it's in the present the whole thing
is in the present past present and
future all in the present that's what
the black universe is so this fell says
the way I understand the black universe
is that it's not the last uh frame the
black universe is the entire film strip
and it always exists both future and
past yeah but see if it's a film strip
then clearly uh you're talking about
each frame being a single slice of time
okay so that's the first issue so no are
being created or destroyed they just all
exist at the same time well that's not
what it is here you see why this is uh
from the official you know group World
there the of mathematical physics and
you can see there I think it's the yeah
the second one there first particles and
then uh first nuclei uh first light and
so on down the line so you can see that
they're being created as we go along
it's not like it all existed at the same
time there was an evolution according to
the official version of the uh of atoms
you know at some point there were
subatomic particles then they bunched
into atoms and eventually into you know
bigger things objects like you know
stars and galaxies and so on so uh no uh
this notion that he's got that it's all
that atoms have always existed according
to the official version is not true
there's been an evolution according to
the official version of particles into
atoms that's one issue the other one is
that you know that space time is divided
into slices those slices are slices of
time and you must understand that okay
that there're slices of time time
requires motion you can't do time
without motion and not only you can't
see it as a single block because it's
divided into time but we're adding new
slices you know the present is moving so
to speak you're having new slices of
time as we move along so you cannot talk
about a single block
Universe uh and again there's a
contradiction there that relativity
never to resolved in fact St Augustine
already had talked about you know the
block Universe he he he invented the
block universe or at least one of the
guys who came up with it first and wrote
about it okay that was in the fourth
Century um fifth fifth century uh water
doesn't get tangled with water one fell
says light doesn't get tangled with
light either and the ropes don't get
tangled with each other either okay and
yeah here's the single thread that we're
referring to and the single thread
um uh essentially has all the properties
that um that we see in our macro World
it has the properties of um what is it
of solids liquids and gases and uh
that's the assumption that we make okay
turns into these atoms and uh the atoms
then you know uh form everything else
and there's your rope you've got two
threads two twine threads and uh builds
all the atoms in the universe but see
all these atoms uh they have the ability
to turn into solids in uh if the thread
there that's uniting them is very U cold
other words low frequency if it has a
little more frequency it becomes liquid
and um um if it becomes um colder in
other words uh I'm sorry low frequency
means solid higher fre frequency means
liquid and even higher frequency means
gas that's all that the Rope does to all
these uh structures but yeah the point
here is that the um as this fell
suggested uh the thread we say that it
already has the properties of that we
see in our macro world of gases liquids
and solids okay the only three states of
matter known to man now some people talk
about what is it plasma something like
that it's the fourth state of matter
and I think they're confusing it you
know they think some state in Canada
belongs to the United States they say
that's the fourth state I don't know
plasma is not a state okay plasma is a
dynamic concept and therefore it's not a
state which is a static concept okay we
don't need to have gases move we don't
need to have water move we don't need to
have solids move but we absolutely need
to have something in motion to have
plasma and people like the electric
universe they they never figure that out
okay so here we have sorry Bill but your
Rob hypothesis is complete buunk oh okay
it is physically impossible okay he's
got to Define what physically is if
we're going to understand them but he
just gave an opinion there okay fine uh
the complexity required for such a
mechanism to work would be
unimaginable I don't know why he has uh
a low capacity for imagination we've
Illustrated it so I mean you know I I
have no idea he cannot why he cannot
imagine it when we drew drawn it and he
could just look at the picture you know
or the watch the film strip okay nature
never does things the hard way well
there we agree right you will have no
real mechanism because you are making
assumptions based on what irrational
ideas yeah if we know what he means by
irrational it's easy to say irrational
he's just giving his opinion he said
anything that doesn't agree with him is
irrational that's all he's saying there
unless unless he defines the word
irrational we don't know what he means
by that word okay so all he's giving us
is his opinion you're saying if quantum
mechanics can suggest BS so can't so can
you oh so can I yeah okay you still need
to explain how your gazillions of
threads could possibly coexist without
being entangled and that's this whole
problem that's this whole stumbling
block he he cannot understand
intangibility that's that's the whole
issue and again you know the problem
there is that we have to have a
definition for what an object is and an
object is not that which you can see or
touch my biggest contribution to science
by the way uh an object is that which
has shape and it can an object has shape
does not mean you can see or touch it we
can't see the air and we can't touch you
know the chair that we can't see the air
and we can't touch the chair on the
other side of the universe right and so
if we can't touch it that means that the
chair is not an object the the word
chair does not refer to an object always
that's the question and that's the first
issue okay but then he continues and he
says the following he says your model
doesn't explain much and require some
sort of intelligence to know how to pull
or to twist like some biological
organism I don't know where he got that
obviously he doesn't understand the
theory The Proposal here but he Contin
says how can an adom know which atoms to
contact and which threads to use how
does a flash light know which atoms to
illuminate on the wall well we we've
Illustrated this here's an illustration
of that or what he's asking there and
here you see it all atoms are already
connected before you turn anything on
okay so before you turn the flashlight
on uh the atoms are all connected by
electromagnetic ropes every atom on the
wall is connected to every atom in this
case of the medium that's put in between
which in this case is a pin okay but
every atom of the pin is connected to
every atom of the wall and every atom of
the flashlight is connected to every
single atom that makes up the pin so
what you have is a relay mechanism and
what he cannot imagine about this only
God knows okay it's very straightforward
all atoms are physically interconnected
so they don't so the atoms already know
in advance why because they're already
connected in advance before you turn on
the light and all you did with when you
turn on the light is stimulate those
ropes to uh TW for to torque at a higher
frequency that's all you did you bring
it into the realm of uh visible light
that's all Sapp in there and again the
wall every atom of the wall is also
connected to your eye that's why you can
see the uh essentially the reflection
what what is reflection just a um you're
relaying uh the uh the signal from the
flashlight first to the wall through the
uh pin and then from the wall directly
to your eye those atoms are pumping at a
higher speed meaning the they T the Rope
at a higher speed and now they bring it
into the uh visible range okay so it's
straightforward uh but this poor fellow
guess uh either hasn't taken the trouble
to understand it or doesn't understand
it because he doesn't have the
sufficient gray
matter and the funny thing about it he's
got he his Monarch put the word sigh
like for science what is a person like
him doing in
science and here you can see he
continues here um well this fell answer
kind of answered him he he put another
uh comment there but essentially he
answers this previous fellow okay and it
says if people can't see it or touch it
they assume there's nothing there that's
that's the whole problem okay I say this
to to them you assume I see nothing
therefore there is nothing to be seen I
know of nothing therefore there's
nothing to be known my conclusion is
that they referring to these people who
think in this way they're fundamentally
different type of
humans okay yeah this was a different
type of human maybe he's not human I
don't know maybe C are on a different
planet for all we know okay and this
well continues he says the following he
says someone already proposed the only
rational mechanism again we don't know
what he means by rational or rational
for gravity and electromagnetism using a
universal what continuous fluid medium
continuous fluid medium uh that's like a
contradiction or self-contradiction
because if it's continuous it's not
fluid and if it's fluid it's not
continuous okay but he doesn't
understand that okay continuous means
made of a single piece that's what
continuous means okay and fluid means
it's made out of particles or subunits
and so he's got a uh made out of a
single single piece thing that has many
parts that's what he's saying there
that's the kind of medium he's got in
the back of his mind if he's got one not
made of any discrete constituents
constituents he put okay uh so there's a
contradiction there you can't have
discrete units and be continuous either
it's discret or Contin those are two
contradictory Notions and again he's
never figure that out and fluid any
fluid has to be made of Parts no matter
what there's no such thing as a fluid uh
made of a single piece unless you assume
make that assumption okay but if you're
just going to talk about fluids like
everyday fluids like water or oil or
whatever then it's made out of atoms out
of particles and so you have to specify
very well what you mean by fluid that is
made out of a single piece at least you
have to make that assumption no problem
if you make that assumption but make
sure you don't talk about fluid in
general because when you talk about
fluids you're talking about molecules
and uh some made out of many molecules
many atoms and then in that case it's
made out of parts and it's not
continuous so again he's got to resolve
those contradictions that he's got there
but he says the following say Michaelson
Mory experiment did not disprove The
Ether in any way uhuh they did not know
what it was meaning The Ether right they
thought it was some sort of fixed
fabric okay uh so uh okay so it's not a
fixed fabric what is it then in the
alter
that has he told us what it is did he
put a link and show us what he proposes
The Ether is so that we can all see it
you know with our eyes and say okay I
know what you're talking about and I I
see what's going through your mind
because you showed me a picture of your
version of The Ether right he didn't do
that he just says oh these people didn't
know what the ether was okay let's see
what he says it is says they did not
know what it was they thought it was
some sort of fixed fabric to disprove
The Ether you first need to have a
pretty good idea idea of what the ether
might
be yeah why don't you tell us you know I
mean' be nice if if he would have told
us he said look this is The Ether and
pointed to a picture of The Ether right
and another fellow goes in there and
also uh kind of doubles down on it says
some uh what is it uh let's see I got
the right one oh I got the same one
anyways I I put the wrong one in there
but another fellow essentially came up
with the same thing and said propos The
Ether and so the question what is this
ether and neither one of them put a link
to the to a picture where we can see
what they're talking about they just
talk about it one guy say it's a fluid
the other one says it's a bunch of
Concepts you know we don't know we don't
know what they're talking about and
again I Define an ether as a person who
does not know what the ether is or who
cannot Define the word ether or who
cannot make a picture of The Ether can I
point to a picture of The Ether that's
an eist because the only thing an eist
never does and never has done on this
channel we've gone through gazillions of
ether here and not one of them has ever
come up with a picture of what they're
talking about so if the ether is a
medium medium means you're going to draw
it you're going to make a picture of it
take a
snapshot uh you know painted we need to
see an image and if you cannot come up
with an image of The Ether don't talk
about The Ether or don't treat it as a
physical object as a medium now if
you're going to Define the word and say
look this is The Ether and you define it
then you can't use it as an object you
can't say The Ether vibrates because
Concepts don't vibrate either it's a
concept or an object there's no other
category either it's an object and you
draw it you illustrate it and you treat
it as a medium as a thing or it's a
concept which is a relation in which
case you can't use it as a thing you
can't say it's going to vibrate it's
going to move it's going to do anything
and they don't understand that uh that's
the first part so that means they
haven't gone through kindergarten
physics uh before they open their
mouths okay so
um uh so what is ether well I think I
have it here give me a
second
uh yeah here it is okay so we're going
to compare The Ether against the ropes
so that they understand what we call The
Ether you don't have to agree but then
your your solution is to point to The
Ether just point to a link somewhere on
theend internet you can upload it you
can put to somebody else's I don't care
but put a link to a picture if you're
going to treat it as a medium medium
meaning it's an object meaning it's got
shape we want to see an image of this
famous ether otherwise you know you
define it in which case it's a concept
and when you can't use it an as an
object okay so here it is this is The
Ether bunch of particles they're
discreete particles they're not
continuous and are they fluid yeah
they're fluid because they're made out
of particles and and compare that to the
what we propose which is interconnected
atoms they're all connected okay you can
see the atoms there they're all
connected by something there so you can
see these two uh assumptions are totally
different The Ether bunch of particles
that vibrate or whatever and you have to
tell us what the black stuff is that's
giving shape to each one of those
particles so we need to know what the
black stuff is there's two things there
in in the on the left hand side you see
some white little things that are uh
moving around
uh Quantum would say they're popping in
and out of existence fine but that's the
ether okay and we're subjecting s
suggesting something else we're making a
different assumption we're saying that
what we have out there in the universe
is a bunch of atoms that are all
interconnected so these two things are
different okay and so if you don't like
The Ether that I put there you're saying
that's not my ether you're wrong Bill
don't tell me I'm wrong I want to see
The Ether your ether don't tell me that
you know what the ether is and that I'm
wrong tell me what the ether is and for
that if it's a thing I want you to point
to the image okay give us a um a little
picture you know some link that shows
the ether and if you don't do it here
I'll do it for you okay one more time
here I'll show you the ether and this is
not mine okay this is if you Google uh
doing images right on Google and this is
what you get for The Ether you get all
these little ether e is out there what
people think the ether is okay and you
can see that uh this is what Michaelson
and Morty worked with okay and the
specific ones I want to show you are the
ones that have all those arrows pointing
in a given Direction across the Earth
and what they're talking about is
particles they're saying there's a sea
of particles essentially a uh sandbox
okay you go to the uh kids playground
you find a Sandbox that's what it is and
and so for some reason they have these
particles vibrate I don't know why but
that's what the ether is a bunch of
particles and what Michaels and Morty
were trying to figure out is if there's
a difference in light traveling Against
The Ether at 90 degrees versus traveling
you know in the same direction as those
particles that's what it was all about
and they showed no difference so they
said there is no ether and these people
say oh the Michaelson morle experiment
was wrong okay no problem then show me
first your ether
then we know what you're talking about
until you show me your ether we have no
idea what you're talking about okay so
the um the onus is on you you know the
ball is in your
court okay so you've got my ether for
you since you don't put the ether I put
it for you if you don't like my ether
you put yours that's how simple it is
don't tell me I'm wrong I know I'm wrong
I'm always wrong I want to know what's
right okay so put your ether don't tell
me I'm wrong okay here we we have um uh
what's his name Mr Brian Green we're
going to start in our uh our
um was it gyroscope SL gravity Pro b um
lecture so here we start with Mr Brian
Green who uh presented that in one of
his uh series okay and that's why I want
to put this all here uh Brian Green this
is his brief bio I got it from different
sources is a string theorist and
mathematician reene was a physics
professor at Cornell from 1990 to 95 and
has been professor at Colombia since
1996 so he's been around for a while
right what 28 years now he is Chairman
of the world Science Festival so he's
quite popular right uh also a
popularizer of physics so-called physics
mathematical physics irrational physics
right green has become known to a wider
audience through his books for the
general public the elegant Universe uh I
Caris Etc uh the only one I'm going to
mention there the fabric of the cosmos
because I'm going to be looking at his
uh I think it was his fourth uh series
installment on that series and that was
um uh he talked about space but in that
same space uh that he analyzed he U
talked about time and why because he
talked about the gravity Pro B which was
used to put you to know where to put the
satellites up there you know for GPS so
it was an important experiment um that
showed where to put the satellites but
uh it um does not explain how all that
works so to this day none of these
people can tell you you know how uh GPS
Works they they tell you look uh all we
know is that when we measure you know
there's a difference in time uh when you
put the the atomic clocks in those
satellites up there in the sky they have
no idea why what causes you know the uh
clock to go slower or faster the ones on
Earth versus the ones up there okay so
uh what we're looking for is
explanations mechanisms causes we want
to know why and that's an answer that no
mathematical physics on planet Earth
with all the GPS we have out there can
answer for you okay so that's the issue
okay the issue is mechanism that's what
we talk about here we talk about physics
not math and when they tell me that time
is dilated and time is bent and I don't
know what they're not talking about
physics because time does not belong to
physics physics we do not use time
because time is a description and in
science we explain we do not describe
okay so here we have this is what he
tried to show that NASA gyroscopes prove
Earth drags what time around itself when
it spins my God it drags time around and
you say Bill
is is this true is this what they try to
show well uh here's a picture of what
they're suggesting right time is being
dragged around
okay okay if this is what they think I
mean whether are is dragging the the
seconds the minutes the seconds right so
we need to know what they're talking
about and uh here's uh from uh
respectable sources you know authorized
sources here you say it uh this is NASA
frame dragging experiment okay and it
says direct evidence that the Earth what
drags space and time around itself as it
rotates now I didn't invent that this is
out of this is out of authoritative uh
sources the research is the most
accurate direct measurement to date of
the la la la effect uh bizarre effect of
general relativity which predicts a
rotating mass will drag space around it
so every time you turn around you're
dragging space forget about air but it's
drag you drag in space as well okay I
guess you got to spin fast enough to
notice the difference uh as the Earth
rotates it what pulls space time so it's
going to pull time as well okay I want
to make sure we they like to talk about
space and they leave the time usually
out because if they just talk about
dragging time around people would say
who that doesn't sound right but when
they say space people think it's a
physical object and so you know they can
get away with more by saying space but
here we're going to show that they're
talking about space and time and they
call it space time and what they're
really talking about is not Dimensions
not cordinates not vectors they're
talking about number lines what they're
dragging around is number
lines okay so here's the gravity Probe
on the right says uh this comes from the
Wikipedia The gyroscopes were intended
to what reveal how space and time are
warped by the presence of the earth and
by how much the Earth rotation what
drags space time around with it I didn't
invent this okay this is in out of all
these sources right and then at the
bottom there's another source there says
in general relativity masses rotation
influences the motion of objects in its
neighborhood put simply the rotating
Mass drags along SpaceTime in the
vicinity okay now what is it that I
didn't understand okay yeah they're
saying you're dragging time around and
you're dragging space around which is
nothing but they claim that space is
this physical object three-dimensional
object and so people get confused they
say well yeah I can probably imagine it
dragging a three-dimensional object
around but when you say just time what
do you mean you drag time and that's
where that's why they don't talk so much
about time they talk more about space
and just in case here we have Stephen
Hawking he clarifies for us just in case
you missed it you know that space and
time there are no differences between
them in the religion of mathematics okay
and here it is he says the following
says in relativity there is no real
distinction between the space and time
what coordinates meaning number lines
they're not talking about coordinates
they're not talking about uh length
width and height or or about um latitude
longitude and altitude they're talking
about
radius um what is it
uh
width uh they're talking about numbers
and what they're talking about is number
lines and they call them Dimensions or
coordinates or whatever where they put
in there okay so they saying there's no
difference between space and time
coordinates meaning number lines right
of course there's no different not in
number line there is a difference
between a coordinate and a dimension but
the mathematicians never figured it out
that coordinates and dimensions refer to
different things Dimensions refer to you
know length width and height there's are
directions in which perpendicular
directions in which an object faces or
points and coordinates the arrows go in
the opposite direction they go from the
walls of your house towards you that's
your location with respect to your house
you know if you take three perpendicular
you know erors coming towards you okay
so that's uh different but
mathematicians treat coordinates and
dimensions and time and everything all
the same because they're all number
lines they're not
Dimensions okay so where does uh good
old Brian Green start when he talks
about um uh this subject about dragging
time around well he starts by showing
that there was a little bit of a
difference between Newton and Einstein
okay so let me put this up here and what
I've done is
um uh I've
um karaoke it behind so all these will
have my voice in the background but
they're the exact uh words used by um
Brian Green in his uh in his Exposition
in his uh Series so here it goes listen
carefully there it
goes back in Newton's time space was
just a container it didn't do anything
at
all then through Einstein space begins
to affect how objects
move okay so uh they're treat uh
starting with Einstein right he's
starting to
treat uh space and time keep in mind the
talking about space time they leave the
word time out because that would create
some a little bit of a problem with a
lot of people and so they talk about
space being able to move and shove
things around so now now it's no longer
the static thing it's it's got this
ability to push things around okay and
here he rubs that in again let me show
you this here he goes listen
carefully where Newton thought spaces p
passive Einstein saw it as
Dynamic interwoven with time and it
dictates how things move so after
Einstein space can no longer be thought
of as a static
stage it's an actor and it plays a
leading role in The Cosmic
drama okay and here you can see um uh
this comes from Stephen Hawkings book
and he does say that space and time do
actually move so you know there's no
contradiction between what um um Brian
Green says and what Hawkins said says
before 1915 space and time were thought
of as fixed Arena but um then he says
space and time are now Dynamic
quantities when a body moves or a force
acts it affects the curvature of space
and time and in turn the structure of
space time affects the way in which
bodies move and forces act okay so you
see this um this uh argument from
mathematical physics so they all agree
the mathematicians the so-called
mathematical physicists you know they
agree that they're saying space and time
move and they have the ability to push
things around okay that means time
pushes on you they're treating as time
as a physical object let that be no no U
you know ambiguity about that uh in fact
they they uh if if they're you're going
to drag time around which is what
gravity prob B essentially proved frame
dragging as they call it uh if you're
going to drag time it had better be a
physical object and so that's what
they're saying here okay I want to make
sure everybody understands that they're
saying that time is a physical object
like a rock or like a tree or like a dog
or something that you can drag right
okay um and here he continues he says
space is not nothing meaning time right
right remember space time right saying
it's not nothing it's something and here
it is this is all out of their their own
you know this is the horse's mouth
speaking there I'm just speaking in the
background because I'm just saying the
same words that they're saying and this
this is all textual this is all verbatim
here he goes listen carefully what if
you took away all the planets stars and
galaxies and not just the big stuff but
tiny things what if you took it all away
what would be left most of us would say
nothing and we'd be right strangely we'd
also be wrong what's left is empty space
and as it turns out empty space is not
nothing it's
something space is so real that it can
bend space can twist and it can
Ripple so real that empty space helps
shape everything in the world around us
and forms the very fabric of the
cosmos
okay so um there you have it uh space
and time are physical objects and he
reinforces that throughout his whole
Exposition his whole lecture his
documentary okay um and just in case uh
he wants to show you an an argument that
he's got of why
space and time remember space time but
he's going to talk mainly about space
but don't let that confuse you he's also
talking about time he's saying that uh
this thingy called space this thingy
called
SpaceTime uh is a physical object
because otherwise you know you have a
skater and she's skating around what is
she moving around with respect to if you
remove all objects in the universe all
atoms everything and here this again
this is the horse's mouth talking here
okay
and let me put him on here he goes
listen
carefully let's imagine that you could
take all the stuff in the universe so
that the only thing left is a skater
spinning with respect to completely
empty
space if the skater still feels her arms
pulled outwards she'll know she's
spinning but if empty space is nothing
what is she spinning in relation to
when she spins her arms play out because
she is spinning with respect to
something and that something is space
itself scientists came up with a Bolden
picture of space the key was to make
something out of
nothing I absolutely love that last
statement yeah they have to make
something out of nothing so we have
nothing out there but they said well if
she's spinning what is she spinning with
respect to and that's why they turn
space time right into a medium because
otherwise you say what is she spinning
with respect to and so they had to turn
nothing which is space what space is or
not uh into something that's what
happened okay and just in case they he
comes up with another bit of proof
evidence and that is that all atoms are
mostly empty space okay so here it goes
listen
carefully you can take the most abundant
thing in the universe even the tiniest
of things like atoms even they are
almost entirely empty space in fact if
you remove all the space inside all the
atoms making up the Empire State
Building you'd be left with a little
lump about the side size of a grain of
rice weighing hundreds of millions of
pounds the rest is only empty
space so where did they get that well
they say uh Rutherford uh ran some
experiments what was in 1919 and he
figured out that an atom is mostly empty
space and everybody just repeats that
today without thinking about it if an
atom is most the empty space meaning
there's a ball in the center and a
little bead going around it you have to
explain why the bead doesn't fall
negative bead falls to the positive
nucleus or why the bead negative bead
doesn't spontaneously fly away they
never explain that they just say it's
mostly empty space meaning between the
electron and the
proton and that's just a statement it's
an irrational statement because they
can't justify why the cause why that
bead stays faithful to the proton
despite being you know one positive the
other one negative it should fall
directly to the nucleus or why does it
fly spontaneously away and of course
they'll never answer that kind of
question but it turns out that if an
atom is mostly empty space what is space
well it turns out that space according
to them is made out of
particles and uh again this comes not
from me okay this comes from Good Old
Brian Green and his uh show and here he
goes listen
carefully according to the rules of
quantum mechanics even if you try to
remove every last atom and particle
you'd find that empty space is still far
from empty in fact it's teeming with
activity particles are constantly
popping in and out of existence they
erupt out of nothingness quickly
annihilate each other and disappear
in quantum mechanics empty space is not
that empty it's full of fluctuating
Fields full of all sorts of jittery
things going on it's a place where
particles are constantly fluctuating and
annihilating each other and being
created again and
annihilating it's a place of chaos and
bubbling so what is empty space made out
of it's made out of particles so we have
particles such as an atom which is made
the empty space and then empty space is
not empty because it's made out of
particles great I mean we've learned a
lot with these people okay okay so uh
they ran this uh gravity Pro B thingy
and they proved with it that uh space is
a physical object meaning space time
keep in mind this is always includes
time they just don't mention time
because Taboo it's kind of uh more
obvious if they just talked about time
so they talk about space which is easier
to push across to people okay so this is
where what he says about
it this experiment buys the most direct
evidence ever found that space is
something real a physical entity like a
fabric after all if space were nothing
there would be nothing to
twist so yeah if you're going to twist
space like he said originally that you
could twist it bend it send waves
through it well if you're going to twist
it it had better be a physical object so
I think there's no I mean he reinforced
that in so many ways that you cannot say
he did not say it he did say time space
space
time physical object it's a thing okay
he never defined what a thing is but
he's saying it's a thing meaning you can
touch it because he's saying space can
push on you meaning space time can push
at you meaning time can push at you
because time and space both move and
they're malleable and you all these good
things okay so um here um they've came
up with this experiment to
prove to people you know to to the to
the general public that
space and time are physical objects and
you can actually drag space and drag
time around the earth and it's called
gravity Pro B that's how they're going
to do it and he gives you a little light
explanation here there but it really you
puts you up to date what the gyroscope
what your billion dollars it was around
800 million but this is I think
conservative I think they spent like a
billion dollars over like 30 years to
develop the this this project and it's
this is what he's got to say about it so
uh this this was the plan they did it
with these gyroscopes perfectly um uh
round
gyroscopes and they're going to point
you know the axis at a star and so
they're going to try to figure out if
when Earth moves around it drags these
gyroscopes in such a way that it takes
them takes that axis off uh pointing to
that star and I think they did it with a
laser okay here goes he's going to
explain it in more detail here
goes normally a gyroscope axis points in
a fixed Direction but if Earth is
actually dragging space then the
gyroscope axis would be dragged along
with it shifting its orientation in a
way that could be
measured NASA attached four freeling
floating gyroscopes to a telescope aimed
at a distance
star if space twists then over time the
gyroscopes would no longer point at the
star since they get caught up in the
swirl of
space okay so that was the the plan that
was the design of the
experiment uh they had a little bit of
pro they had a little bit of a problem
because you know you really want to
control that you want to make sure that
there's no change for some other reason
that has nothing to do with the uh Earth
dragging time around okay so that was
the issue but it turns out they
encountered a problem and he States it
at least they were honest about that and
I want you to consider this uh when you
factor whether they were honest or not
or whether they you know kind of fudged
the data to match what they want you
know their preconceived uh ideas for
this and here it goes listen to
this for over a year gravity Pro B
orbited the Earth while NASA monitored
whether the Earth would actually twist
space the data began to trickle in and
there was a problem the gyroscopes were
experiencing a tiny unexpected
wobble and to clean up the data would
cost
Millions over the next two years years
the problem with the data was solved
revealing that the axis of the gyroscope
shifted by almost exactly the amount
predicted by Einstein's
equations so uh there was a problem and
the problem was a big problem because we
were talking about
wobbling and kind of like you know that
was what they were testing and so if
it's wobbling for some other reasons
then your experiment is all shot out you
it's no good but they're saying they
cleaned up the data you know what I mean
they cleaned it up and uh they got rid
of all the bad data it turns out just by
sheer coincidence the deviation from the
axis matched Einstein's
equation coincidentally what what a
coincidence you know uh that's something
you should keep in mind okay uh
personally I don't know whether it did
or not whether they fud the data or not
seems like they did but I think it's
irrelevant anyways because again their
conclusions are what's uh important and
you would think that after all that
testing after you know doing all these
experiments and uh looking at Einstein's
equation about space and time you would
think they'd have a great handle on both
space and time okay so this is what how
um uh good old Brian Green uh concludes
his presentation and you really should
listen to this because this is his
conclusion this is uh this shows you how
much they learn from all this about you
know what space and time are okay and
here it is this the this is how he ends
his presentation here it goes for
something that is a vital part of our
everyday lives space remains kind of
like a familiar stranger it's all around
us but we're still far from having
unmask its true
identity that may take 100 years it may
take a thousand years or it may happen
tomorrow but when we solve that mystery
we will take a giant step towards fully
understanding the fabric of the
cosmos okay so after all that he has no
idea what space or time are what
SpaceTime is it's like they don't care
they just say it's a physical object
because it can push you okay they
measured it they showed that through an
experiment that um space and time or
Time by itself time space by itself
pushed the gyroscopes aside and changed
the axis of orientation there okay so
they did all this fancy stuff and after
all that's said and done he still cannot
tell you what space is or what time is
and in fact here you have um today's
Notions okay see if I can find this here
these are uh bured by dictionaries and
encyclopedias this is what space and
time are so if you taking notes get a
pencil and pen and uh write this down
because uh we're going to take have it
on the test on Friday here it is yeah
this is what space and time are outer
space or simply space is the what
expanse whatever expanse is is the
expanse Beyond celestial bodies and
their
atmosphere uh so what we have is an
expanse whatever that an expanse is
outer spaces is not completely empty
okay we don't care if it's empty or not
what is it but they're saying so they
think it's a container which is what
Newton said originally so they're
treating it as a container it's just a
movable or a moving a malleable
container right uh maybe like a balloon
I don't know uh maybe uh it is uh near
perfect vacuum whatever that means you
know because what's a vacuum you vacuum
is made out of particles because vacuum
is space so I don't know what they're
talking about unless they can draw this
entity they call space vacuum
nothingness you know that we have no
idea what they they're talking about
containing a low density of particles
containing or made of that's the
question I mean a space a container or
is
it or is it made of particles like this
guy said originally so they have all
these contradictions space is a
container but it's a container of what
it's a container of atoms Etc galaxies
whatever you got in there but then space
itself is made out of atoms according to
them and so we we have this circular
argument if it's made out of atoms
what's between or about not atoms but
particles what's between the particles
because when I have two particles here
here I have two particles right here
let's call these two particles well
hopefully there's space between them
because otherwise we wouldn't have
discrete particles there's got to be
some medium
that uh goes all around this ball for me
to conceptualize this ball and so if
space is made out of particles what's
giving a background what's giving a uh
uh what's contouring each one of these
particles so we still don't know what
that stuff is that you know gives shape
to the space particles that come in from
the void whenever they the mathematician
requires them what is time well let's
find out time is the continued sequence
of
existence and events that occurs yeah in
an apparently irreversible succession
from the past through the present and
into the future and the problem there is
if you look at the word past present and
future they're defined in terms of time
so we have a circular definition time is
past present and future and past present
and future is time great we've learned a
lot defining time is in a manner
applicable to all Fields without
circularity has concern consistently
eluded the
scholars so that's a great way of ending
your presentation you start the
presentation saying we're going to prove
to you and convince you that we know
what we're talking about and they end
their presentation saying oh we're still
researching we have no idea what space
or time are but we know for a fact
through experiments that uh the Earth
drags time around itself and so do you
when you skate you know turn around like
a skater uh twirl around spin you know
you're dragging time around don't go
into a carousel you know a merry go
around because you're going to be
dragging you know time around yourself
and yeah if you go to a Carousel and
spend some money there you'll be
spending a lot of time believe me you
daging a lot of time around yourself so
that's the bottom line you know they do
these experiments and they come out with
all these physical
interpretations when you point some of
these things out to them they end up
saying well you know the the fact is
that all that's philosophy
we just do math and then the question
that you always should ask him is why
did you attempt to give a physical
interpretation if it's not your uh in
your job description if it's not in your
line of work why did you give a physical
interpretation if you do equations and
you call physics equations no problem
but keep it within equation don't jump
the fence into physics and say I can
tell you how the universe works why it
works the way it does and you give a you
know they they even illustrate it
and what they're illustrating is
nonsense they're illustrating what
that's what they're illustrating how uh
the Earth drags time
around that's what they illustrate and
so this is their conclusion so you
cannot say that these people have
learned anything or know anything about
time that they can explain anything
about how the universe works and this is
the bottom line you know so uh yeah uh
all you can say is that they still know
nothing with that I'll see you next week
hopefully on Sunday we'll see you then
byebye